it's a barbiturate the usual ones are
Seconal or pentobarbital they can be
emptied into an ounce glass of liquid
and then it's the individual who has to
ingest that drink they have to be able
to do it completely on their own the
universal setting has been usually in a
person's home and the persons in their
bedroom
family sometimes friends are gathered
it's not necessarily a particularly
mournful situation in certain people
there there is a great sense of
empowerment and their ability to to do
this
you may have a right to control your own
life but what about the right to control
how it ends the aid and dying or
physician assisted suicide debate is
playing out in a place you might not
expect Montana this is Big Sky Country
vast and sparsely populated with local
politics dominated by conservative
Republicans but it's also the third
state to legalize physician assisted
suicide it just doesn't fit the crunchy
granola stereotypes of the other two
Washington and Oregon there is a long
tradition here going back to frontier
days people basically saying that there
are certain areas the government ought
to stay out of Mark Connell was a lead
attorney on the landmark assisted
suicide case Baxter vs. Montana lawyers
like me typically handle fairly routine
cases on a regular basis and this is a
case that had great societal importance
and great personal importance at the
center of the case was this man Robert
Baxter a former US Marine and long-haul
trucker who fell ill to lymphocytic
leukemia as he grew sicker and weaker
Baxter decided he wanted to hasten the
end of his life but no doctor would
prescribe him the medication he needed
to do so so he turned to Conn Bob
approached us and asked if there was
anything we could do from a legal
standpoint to try to gain access to
medications that if he chose to use them
will allow him to hasten his death he
knew he was gonna die the only question
was how much how long that was going to
take and how much suffering is going to
go through when Connell one is case
before a district judge he called Baxter
to share the good news and his wife
answered the phone
I told her what had happened and she
said well Bob would be delighted that he
was a sleep right then was not available
to come the phone and the iron is he
never woke up Bob died without ever
learning you just won that case the
Baxter case went all the way to Montana
Supreme Court and finally established
the legality of assisted suicide
throughout the entire state but that was
just the beginning of this fight all of
our utopian novels brave new world 1984
agenda21 government assisted suicide are
often really non-productive
it's all a theme in the background state
representative Creighton Kearns
House bill 505 designed to outlaw
assisted suicide once and for all when
it comes to assisted suicide currents
has two big concerns big government and
God our lives do in fact belong to God
he will call us when it's time and not
before it's the way I live my life in a
way I've encouraged other people who
live theirs do you think it's without a
doubt without a doubt because we cannot
separate the two I just don't think
there should be any role for government
in telling somebody what to do between
the privacy of them and their doctor and
their family and their health care
providers at the end of life like this
Missoula dr. Eric crest runs a family
practice he never wanted to be at the
center of this controversy but one day a
certain patient changed everything
he was a man who is now 120 pounds of
skin and bone he used to be over six
feet two he was a very strong physical
athletic man he made his desire and
intentions very well known to me that he
wanted this medication but it was new I
wasn't really all that familiar with it
he became very angry with me and he
dressed me down he yelled at me he also
called me a coward and he made me think
about this situation and what happened
as I didn't write him the prescription
and then within a month or two he had
stockpiled enough medication and he
ingested a large amount and ended up
killing himself and I had to kind of ask
myself you know why didn't I do it I can
do this am I worried about me or am I
gonna worry about him since then dr.
kress has become an outspoken advocate
the bill clearly states that any doctor
nurse or family member who assists a
patient in obtaining an aid in dying
prescription will be sentenced to ten
years in prison and fined $50,000 so you
may be wondering what kind of doctor is
it that you will be sending to jail
I stand before you today and state that
I am that kind of doctor I have written
an aid in dying prescription on three
occasions
rather than shirk and hide from it I
want to be honest with with people and
society and tell them what I've done and
to be honest I'm I'm proud of what I'm
done I urge you to vote against House
bill 505 a bill that would be the
government taking of a personal freedom
that the citizens of Montana now enjoy
ten years in prison for prescribing
someone a medication but they ask for
anything that's a maximum that's a
maximum they will it won't I can't
imagine it occurring with a full
implementation of Obamacare government
is going to provide all your health care
the minute you become a non productive
citizen you're out of here
there are always ways outside of the
government's assisted suicide is it any
more or less traumatic one way or the
other I don't know I don't know
there certainly are other ways to hasten
your own death people living in places
where aid and dyeing remains illegal
sometimes take matters into their own
hands I think the reason that I don't
fear death is that a I see it as a
natural process I think most people are
fearful of dying in pain this is et rue
listen a 97 year old retired California
doctor his lifelong love of science in
the natural world informs his outlook on
life and death that was rattling around
in the craw of a dinosaur a hundred and
sixty million years ago me a perspective
to life that's helpful brew listen is a
free spirit who lives in his own home
with his wife and his books and that's
how he plans to die whether the state
likes it or not when I closed my office
3040 years ago in 1976 I had leftover
narcotics that I didn't want to destroy
and have tucked them away and I have a
supply for myself that I will be able to
use if the
if it ever comes to the point where I
needed this is giving me the ability not
to fear death from a painful death
and that for me is made it very
comfortable to think about dying in that
constructive way but not everyone is a
retired doctor with medical knowledge
and access to powerful narcotics some
people just want to die as peacefully
and painlessly as possible and that's
where dr. kress says the physician plays
an important role the suicide is someone
taking their own life and they want to
take their own life
with Aiden dying this is people that
would rather live they'd rather be
healthy they'd rather live but they have
a terminal disease they've been dealt a
card in life that's a it's a tough one
and they are going to die it's a
question of how are they going to die
and we are aiding them in the dying
process we do have a tradition in the US
that the government really doesn't get
in the way of the doctor and the patient
and their decision making what's right
for them especially governing what a
doctor and a patient would even talk
about we're supposed to have free speech
and you're telling me what I can or
can't talk to a patient about that is
crazy this this is not good for for
America for Montana or patients and
doctors 23 senators having voted I am 27
Senators having voted no hospital
not past second reading senator Riddick
if I have any final words to say it
would be to the California Legislature I
hope you will seriously consider
legislation that will provide Death with
Dignity as a possibility for anybody who
chooses
you